among the top 10 most valuable tech
companies globally are to China tech
giants with many more up-and-coming
startups making their presence felt the
industry has become a serious rival to
Silicon Valley but there are political
hurdles ahead this is your bloomberg
quick take on China's tech giant's early
on Chinese companies like $0.10 had a
reputation for being copycats its QQ
instant messaging app originally looked
a lot like ICQ a popular messaging app
used in the u.s. I would say 90% of them
all got their original aspiration from a
u.s. equivalent Sina for example their
portal business was an equivalent of
Yahoo Wave was an equivalent of Twitter
Alibaba people would say that their
model is a hybrid of eBay and Amazon and
so the list goes on comparisons are now
harder to make 10 cents 1 billion strong
messaging at WeChat has grown from
simply a texting app to a platform for
shopping flirting dating watching videos
playing games and ordering food in taxis
there's no US equivalent since the
introduction of the Internet in China's
the government has controlled the web
with a complex system of sensors and
gateways known as the Great Firewall
this is effectively quarantined China's
technology ecosystem blocking access to
the likes of Facebook Twitter and
Instagram that's enabled locals to
develop services without competition
from abroad and build platforms with a
uniquely Chinese flavor and because of
China's large population whose Internet
users more than double the entire US
population the companies grew to be
massive they became so successful that
some US companies are taking note I
think a lot of people would point to a
Facebook trying to copy the we trap
model where they are allowing third
parties to open ecommerce doors through
party games being introduced to the
platform but there's increasing pushback
China
they're draining us they're taking our
money they're rebuilding themselves
President Donald Trump says China is
stealing overseas know-how and has
imposed tariffs bloomberg businessweek
uncovered that the Chinese even planted
chips and computers for potential
Hardware hacks two years ago we were
seeing a lot of investment M&A activity
into technology in Silicon Valley from
Chinese companies and that's all been
put on breaks ever since the trade war
yet Chinese tech company names that only
recently drew blank stares outside China
are becoming increasingly familiar take
Huawei it reached a pinnacle in 2018 by
overtaking Apple and smartphone share
globally but for China's big tech
companies to keep expanding they'll need
to convince other nations that they mean
no harm
you